c'est le symbole de tout ce qui ne
tournait pas rond en ukraine le domaine
luxueux avec des passages secrets et des
ascenseurs en or un petit paradis pour
deux construits par l'ancien président
viktor ianoukovitch
avant qu'il soit chassé du pouvoir en
c'était pour lui et sa copine on
explique notre guide giulia avant de
dévoiler la pièce de résistance
bienvenue dans ce qu'on appelle le musée
de la corruption en ukraine du milliard
points 5 euros l'arize l'ensemble
certains visiteurs leur même de rage
quand il se rend compte de l'opulence le
palais a été construit avec l'argent
volé au peuple dit série les tchenko qui
voit un lien direct entre ce musée et
les pressions qu'exerce aujourd'hui dans
notre choix mais son avocat vous donne
guiliani sur l'ukraine pour enquêter
dubaï de ce sont les zones grises de la
politique est celle qui en sait quelque
chose
c'est lui ancien journaliste et ancien
conseiller de zielinski qui a fait
tomber le directeur de campagne de
données 3par mana forte en 2016
en révélant qu'il avait empoché ici même
des millions de dollars souillées du
pouvoir en ukraine
aujourd'hui il est dans la mire de
julian qui l'accusent d'être au sein
d'un complot démocrate et si ce qui
selon lui nourrit le désir de vengeance
du président franck et son avocat c'est
incroyable et désolant 10 derrière
calais nuke qui est une des militants
anticorruption les plus respectés du pis
de voir le président des états unis
appelé celui de l'ukraine et lui
demander de vie voix de s'ingérer dans
le travail de nos procureurs pour salir
en rival samyn dit-elle à toutes les
leçons de bon goût
dans ce que les états unis vandales
ukraine depuis des années et cela ne
peut que nuire aux relations entre les
deux pays c'est mauvais pour l'ukraine
mais en apparence cette femme d'autant
plus que notre président les pourriels
mais celui qui pourrait éventuellement
être appelé à témoigner au congrès à
washington voit les choses différemment
une occasion pour les ukrainiens 10
séries de se redéfinir sur la scène
internationale comme nation qui tourne
le dos aux démons du passé et le musée
de l'art de la corruption et des escrocs
et là exactement pour rappeler une
crinière ce qui est en jeu ici tamar
altérer ce coup radio canada